todos los residentes de cremators tienen
derecho a recibir ayuda humanitaria a la
que se inscriben en oficinas como ésta
esto una copia de la orden gubernamental
de evacuación información sobre el
transporte gratuito y un formulario de
exclusión para los que estén decididos a
quedarse es obligatorio rellenar Esto
no es obligatorio pero si recomendable
así las autoridades saben que está aquí
Elena se va pero no puede convencer a su
madre para que la acompañe
de todos modos Dile que siempre puede
llamar a estos números para el
transporte si cambia de opinión Pero a
dónde evacuan a la gente región de
quirobogrado o led biff nunca querrá ir
allí pero gracias a Dios
se va a declamar
me siento fatal pero no hay nada que
pueda hacer
no quiero quedarme Aquí tengo nietos y
quiero vivir para verlos más
sin embargo la mayoría de los que aún no
se han ido no quieren hacerlo nuestra
tarea es convencerles de que tienen que
evacuar porque el invierno Será muy
difícil
pero hasta ahora no todo el mundo está
de acuerdo
según la Constitución nadie tiene
derecho a obligarnos a evacuar es
nuestra decisión tenemos al ejército
ucraniano en esta ciudad creo que nos
protegerán
alrededor de una cuarta parte de la
población de antes de la guerra
permanecen cromatorsk los servicios
municipales mantienen los refugios
antibombas donde algunos residentes
viven ahora de forma permanente nuestros
chicos dijeron que habían arreglado todo
pero al salir ahora comprobaré si
realmente han despejado la salida de
emergencia para que si Dios no lo quiera
pasa algo tengas una ruta de emergencia
por donde salir los niños hacen sus
clases en línea aquí incluyendo el
deporte
Cómo se compara la educación en línea mi
hijo no se queda en su pupitre para
todas las lecciones va y se acuesta y la
sigue en su tableta así aún así Tania
prefiere quedarse aquí que ser evacuada
donde nos llevarían a dormir en
colchones en el suelo en algún pabellón
deportivo o algo así no quiero eso
[Música]
Alexis a Mixco desempeña dos funciones
un tanto contradictorias tranquilizar a
la gente diciéndole que los refugios
están las condiciones y sugerirles que
se vayan qué tal si te evacuamos
acropiclinsky o al
diniproba
no quiero irme mi casa sigue siendo mi
casa y de todos modos hay bombardeos por
todas partes
el vaso que te haga decir basta nos
vamos de la ciudad
solo temporalmente
llevarte a algún sitio
tiene una idea
cuando la temperatura descienda por
debajo del punto de congelación creo que
harán las maletas tranquilamente y
aceptarán la evacuación porque no podrán
calentar sus casas
las empresas de servicios públicos aquí
están drenando las tuberías antes de que
se congelen Rusia ha ocupado dañado
partes clave del sistema de gas en la
región de donieetsk y es posible que no
haya calefacción en absoluto este
invierno Ese es el principal motivo del
nuevo impulso de evacuación cuyo centro
es esta estación de ferrocarril desde
donde los trenes gratuitos llevan a la
gente al oeste los pasajeros de estos
trenes siguen pensando que es la lucha y
no el frío de lo que usen
tenemos por nuestros hijos tal vez a
donde vamos sea mejor que donde estamos
no tiene sentido sentarse y esperar
hasta que su propia casa sea impactada
sin embargo eso es exactamente lo que le
ocurrió a andrey viejos
porque mi casa puede destrozada
cuanto ayer por la noche
durmiendo un cohete aterrizó cerca y
voló las ventanas las puertas y el techo
antes de eso nuevo acqué porque Gracias
por la comida porque pensaba que la
guerra terminaría pronto
Andrés se ha hecho amigo de una familia
de Back una de las ciudades más
afectadas de
son casi las 4 de la mañana cuando el
tren llega a kroppy en el centro de
Ucrania desde aquí viajan en autobús
hasta un pueblo situado a 30 kilómetros
para ser recibidos por los trabajadores
municipales
en el marco de un programa gubernamental
los pueblos de esta región se han
movilizado para poner a disposición de
los evacuados los edificios que tienen
esto servirá por ahora está bien Mejor
que estar en la zona de combate
mejor aquí que allá en el bombardeos
Y ahora qué Seguiremos viviendo
eso es